Hello 大家好，欢迎回到古典不耽调。本期播客呢，咱来聊聊如何用音乐对抗情绪内耗这件事。
先说说我自己吧，我是NFJ资深内耗型选手。对内耗这件事儿怎么说呢，早期我也是深受其困扰，虽然目前已经好转很多，但是也是依旧在与其斗争的这么一个状态。
唯一可能比较倾向的是我不太会深夜内耗，就是那种大半夜躺在床上脑子跟过电影一样，回放白天发生的事情，比我想到自己做过的傻事儿说过的纯化，并且会伴随着无比尴尬、悔恨、懊恼、这种内耗我会比较少。
我觉得大部分的内耗呢都会集中在刚发生的那几个小时。
举个例子，我这个人经常就是好心办坏事儿，本意是好的，但有时候嘴巴比脑子快。
加上我这个人性格挺直的，尤其是在我20岁出头的时候，感觉得罪了不少人。
当然现在经过职场和社会的磨练已经是好多了。
但是说话不会拐歪这个事儿吧，就是刻在我DNA里的。
我经常就是说了一句自认为是没什么问题的话，但对方好像没有给到我的好意，甚至可能误解了我。
那如果这个人刚好是我很重视的朋友，那我完了。
接下来几个小时我整个人就像被钉在那儿了，干事儿呢总走神，
脑子里也会反复重播刚才的对话，心里开始疯狂盘算，我要不要再给他发一句什么，招步一下。
至少让两个人的聊天在一个比较开心的氛围中结束，这样也方便开启下一次的快乐聊天。
但紧接另外一个声音就会冒出来，人家可能已经烦你了，你再发一条是不是更招人烦。
OMG，太宁吧。
虽然在小宇宙里面有很多播客，包括播主，他们都已经聊过类似的话题。
我也在做这期播客之前特意听了一些，有一些是专业项目的会结合一些心理学的理论，给你掰开柔碎的分析。
比如谈恋人那期高敏感的人怎么体验这个世界。
这期我真的听了蛮多遍的，因为本人就是高敏感体质。
有一些是场景型的解决方案，比如Oga有一期职场不内耗包典。
还有一些或者说绝大部分都是以分享个人经历为主，然后从中体验出自己对抗内耗的方式，像李敬、杨天真、竹子他们都聊过。
但古典不单调，毕竟是一个音乐播客嘛。
我觉得我没有办法从本质上去深度解析每一种内耗的成因，但是作为一个与内耗对抗多年的人，
我觉得解决内耗的本质其实就是转移注意力，把自己从那个对自我过度凝视的黑洞里面拽出来。
无论是去散步，看书，找人聊天，还是我们今天要聊的主题，听音乐。
当我新的信息输的时候，注意力自然而然就被转移了。
而在以上提到的所有转移注意力的方式里，我觉得听古典音乐是成本最低，最惩事，甚至都不用现场摇人，
是一个人戴上耳机就能够解决问题的最有效的途径。
它不仅能够让你停止内耗，还能让你在这个过程当中收获美妙的情感体验，甚至让情绪慢慢稳定下来。
所以本期我给这个歌单设置了三个场景，也是我自己遇到过最多的且清测通过听古典音乐可以有效解决的三种内耗类型。
分别是，身心、具皮是内耗，主要是针对那些让人很烦的事。
换德换师型内耗，主要是针对人。
最后就是自闭式内耗，主要是针对周到的环境。
当然如果波克田的朋友们并不是内耗性人格，也可以完全把它当作一个如何对抗焦虑，
如何让自己慢下来，让自己情绪放松下来的这么一期轻松的音乐波克来听。
那么同样，本期波克分享的八手作品都会在我的同名公众号古典不单调中更新。
推文里会有歌单和详细的曲目信息，欢迎大家关注。
那我们先来说第一个场景，就是哪些音乐可以对抗身心、具皮是内耗。
刚刚我们听到的是早期浪漫主义的奥地利作曲家舒伯特写于1827年的《降G大调》即兴趣。
作品号是第八九九，其中的第三首。
现在我们来还原一个场景，你正在开着车去上班，脑子里正在飞速的过着今天要出业的事情，在心里去排那些优先级。
但与此同时，脑子里又不受控的闪回，昨天的一些遗留事项。
人坐在车里玩的高架上又堵，还一不小心在小心事的过程中，被右侧的车插队了。
这可能导致你上班打卡也得迟到了。
OMG，心里肯定会乱糟糟的，完全静不下来。
我一般在车上遇到这种情况的时候，就会放舒伯特的这首急性曲。
它也是我长期的制定小曲。
这首急性曲写于舒伯特生命的最后一年，属于他晚期钢琴作品的精华。
所谓的急性曲是当时流行的一种钢琴小品题材，风格精致，具有急性和浪漫的色彩。
不过大家别被这个名字给骗了，舒伯特的急性曲的结构其实还是非常严谨和精妙的，一点都不随意。
我们听周曲的时候可以留意它的结构，它是一个典型的ABA三段体结构。
曲子在开始，左手就铺开一串持续流动的分解和弦，营造出一个不便的，相对平稳的音乐背景。
右手则做出一条极其优美的且幼长的旋律，像一首没有词的歌。
两者叠加，左手是静的底色，右手是动的轻速，而你坐在车里，或者是房间的卧室里，外表很安静，但内心却有千言万语想要流淌出来的状态。
到了这个连接步大家注意听，音乐开始有了一些变化，旋律线条被一些单音更清晰的勾勒出来，情绪在一点一点的往上推。
一层一层的继续力量。
而整个曲子就是在这种层层叠叠的情绪推动中前行的。
到了中段就是弊段，情绪会转向更深层更不安的调行。
像是内心那些阴霾和压抑被彻底翻出来了。
但神奇的是，舒伯特并没有让这种不安感失控。
在中段结束之后，音乐又回到了开头那个歌唱性的旋律，也就是A段在线。
一切就被化解开了。
我们先听到这儿，大家有没有觉得他非常巨像的描绘了一个人从预门到内心挣扎，再到最终释怀和想通的全过程。
当音乐带着你走完了这一圈，你心里的那件事好像也跟着被梳理了一遍，就不会再那么拧罢了。
所以下次当你在觉得心里非常堵得慌，什么事都干不下去的时候，
不妨给自己留出这六到七分钟的时间，把这首将这一大条急性曲作为一个情绪急杀车。
下面是纯响之间，给大家播放的是克里斯蒂安琪莫尔曼的版本。
今天有两首都是他演奏的版本，我真的太喜欢他了。
他的触见非常讲究，每个音都像被仔细擦拭过一样，很干净，很透明。
尤其是这种舒伯特，他弹出来那种呼吸感，几乎让人忘记，这是钢琴在发声。
身心具皮式的第二个可能性，适合在你终于决定放下手头的工作传口气，可以一个人出门赛行的瞬间。
那么在这个时候，大家不妨编散步，编听听巴赫的这首箭盘写奏曲。
刚我们听到的是巴赫F小调第五号箭盘写奏曲的第二乐章，作品号是BWV1056。
大家可以想象这样一个画面，你把手头的破射扔到一边，决定出门走一走。
可能是去附近的公园，也可能只是沿着街道漫无目的的溜的。
你插着耳机，脚步不快不慢。
这时候你需要一首既不太会抢戏，又不太寡淡无聊的音乐，陪你走完这段路。
巴赫的这组写奏曲的来历挺有意思的，这是他在莱比希时期写的。
如果大家好奇巴赫的这个生评，可以去听听我的EP6。
里面有讲到这个莱比希时期是巴赫非常高产，也写过很多著名代表作的时期，还包括哥的宝便奏曲。
他在当时担任莱比希音乐协会的总监，需要为每周的音乐会准备曲目。
那么这个工作量是非常巨大的。
所以他把自己以前写的一些小琴写奏曲，一些小作品重新改编，写成了这一批箭盘写奏曲。
在巴赫的时代，箭盘乐器主要是指语管剑琴、harpsichord。
我们现在听到的钢琴版本其实是后人的改编。
巴赫自己大概没有想到，在200多年之后，这些曲子会在钢琴上发出完全不一样的光彩。
那么这首F小调第五号箭盘写奏曲，就是他的这个箭盘写奏曲系列中的一部节作。
下面我们来说说在散步的时候，听周曲子一种听法，也就是个箭一样。
我觉得大家可以先不要把所有的注意力都集中在这个箭盘的旋律上，咱可以留意一下伴奏。
大家可以听到里面有轻微的弦乐波弦。
巴赫在这里用了一种极其克制的配气方式，弦乐组从头到尾几乎都在波弦，
形成一种轻盈有弹性的节奏骨架。
像心跳，也像是脚步，那种细微的跳动感和在散步时的步伐频率，刚好能对上。
身心聚皮式的第三种可能性，就是虽然你内心极度煎熬，但身体却累得完全无法动态，
只能一个人握在家里，哪也去不了的时候。
那么这种时候，咱们可以来听听这首二十世纪的简约派作品。
这段音乐来自美国当代作曲家菲利福格拉斯的第六号练习曲。
大家可以想象一下，当你握在家里，但面前有一堆工作要处理，
你可能刚在线上跟人沟通完，但结果不太理想，有点郁闷，
但手头事情还是得做，也没法出去散心。
人坐在那儿，心里却乱糟糟的，完全进不下来。
你想集中注意力做些什么，但思绪乱飞，完全不受控。
这时候我一般就会听这首菲利福格拉斯的练习曲。
那么格拉斯呢，她是简约主义音乐的电机人之一，
也是当今在世最具影响力的当代作曲家之一。
她的音乐语言用一句话概括就是，
在一个非常有限的和声框架内，
通过极简的素材不断重复和威遍，
制造出巨大的情感张力。
那么她的这个练习曲拳击一共有20首，
创作跨度从1994年到2012年，
是为钢琴而写的技术型练习曲级。
王宇家曾录制了格拉斯的全部二手练习曲，
也获得了格拉斯本人的高度认可。
而且这张专辑让很多古典乐迷第一次如此直观的。
感受到了简约主义音乐的魅力。
我们今天听的版本也是王宇家的演奏，
但是是比较近的一个录音了，
是他在2024年，我也读奏音乐会当中录的曲目。
这也是王宇家非常喜欢的一个。
读奏音乐会的一个保留曲目吧，我觉得算是。
那么这首第六号练习曲到底有什么特别之处呢，
我们拆开来看看。
首先他非常适合需要集中注意力，
但思绪又停不下来的时刻。
曲子开头非常的简单，
左右手交替弹奏同一个音形，
反复隐隐的向前流动。
选择线条隐藏在快速跑动的音符里，
适应实现。
众音乐的有个特点，
没有什么戏剧性的爆发，
也没有什么意外的转掉，
他就在那边隐隐塑的前进。
其次就是简约派音乐的重复性，
这恰好是我们这种内耗型选手的旧型。
那么内耗本质是什么，
就是大脑在同一个死胡同里反复的打转，
而格拉斯音乐也是重复，
但他的重复是有方向的，
大家可以听那些不断循环的音形，
大脑就会被不自觉的拽进那种流动的节奏里。
心跳、呼吸都会慢慢跟着音乐同步，
那批脱江的思维的野蛮，
好像被一根看不见的江神轻轻拉住了。
第三，当你觉得不得劲的时候，
这曲子也会有高潮。
这首练习曲的厉害之处在于，
他重复着重复着，
会在一个意想不到的地方层层堆叠。
右手开始加速，身部开始分化，
音乐被注入了新的能量，
冲着一个明确的高点冲过去。
那种爆发不是轰鸣式的，
而是一种内在的，隐忍的爆发。
结果你憋了很久的一口气，
终于吐了出来。
然后在高潮过去之后，
音乐会重新回到那种平静的流动中，
你会发现，
刚才那股不得劲的情绪，
已经被音乐带走了。
你坐在那儿，
而这个音乐还在继续跑动，
但那心已经安静下来了。
OK，下面我们来聊聊第二种内耗场景，
患得患失是内耗，
也就是对人产生的那种拧马感。
现在我们听到这段来自。
舒曼的A小调钢琴写头曲，
作品号第54，
第一乐章，快版。
这首曲子是我在Sportify的。
每周推荐里面，
第一次完整听完的，
使得除了我自己收藏的歌单，
我平时还挺依赖Sportify的。
每周推荐的，
可能真的是听多了，
在这个APP上面花了很多时间，
而且我在这个APP上面的用户行为。
也比较的精准，
我会非常明确，
它到底是我的喜欢音乐里面，
放在那个like里面，
还是它收藏在我的某个，
其他歌单里面，
或者是我是收藏整首作品，
还是收藏整个专辑，
这种行为我觉得我做的非常的精准，
所以Sportify的算法有时候。
真的是挺懂我的，
我每周一都会打开那个周推，
然后一手一手往下听，
不挑不切就让它自己放，
于是在某个周一，
书卖的这种钢鞋就在周推里跟我相遇了，
但我一开始其实并没有马上。
给到这个作品，
因为它在开头的情绪很满，
那么这种处理在浪案主义鞋头区里面，
其实是挺常见的，
比如格里格的A小雕钢鞋，
老柴的第一钢鞋，
都是类似的路数，
都是先身夺人，
气势拉满，
所以听多了难免会少些惊喜，
所以我当时第一反应就是。
这又是一首典型浪漫主义开场，
没什么特别，
但那天也不知道怎么回事，
我心烦意愿到什么也干不下去，
就让这种作品继续放着，
直到钢琴独奏进来，
我马上被吸引，
那个旋律像是带着试探性的姿态，
从键盘上流淌出来，
它不是那种声势浩大的主题，
也不是那种技术炸裂的炫技段落，
就那么几个音符，
重复着，缠绕着，
像一个人在心里反复念到着，
同一句话，
很轻,
但很有吸引力，
我的脑子就这么被它带走了，
等回过程来，一段已经放完了，
我甚至都没有意识到自己刚才在想什么，
那种烦躁感，
确实被清空了一小块。
这种旋律的写法，
实在是太舒漫了，
熟悉舒漫的朋友们应该知道，
它的音乐里面有一种。
非常特别的旋律走向，
就是听起来很温柔，
但总带着一些没落定的。
玄智感，
它不会直直的走到终点，
而是让一个弯，
探口气，
再回来。
那么这一点呢，
大家也可以在它的一些。
钢琴小品里面听到，
比如说童年情景里面的。
梦幻曲，
就是那种欲言又止的点心，
它的钢琴套曲，
蝴蝶里面那些短小的，
像碎片一样的舞曲，
也是很有代表性的，
还有就是它的艺术歌曲，
诗人之恋里面的第一首，
那个旋律从头到尾，
也没有一个真正的安定的那种落点，
那么回到作曲家来pose一下，
这种旋律的可能性，
那么舒曼这位作曲家呢，
他本身就是浪漫主义作曲家里面，
有分裂性人格的那种作曲家，
他的音乐里有一种双重人格在拉扯，
而且他也给自己有一个。
这种双重人格的比名，
分别是弗雷特斯坦和埃塞比伍斯，
一个热烈冲动，
一个温柔内心，
而且他一生都在这两种。
极端之间摇摆，
所以，如果你此刻正在因为。
某个人的一句话，
一个表情，
再反复的纠结，
不妨把这首写作曲的第一乐章。
从头听到尾，
让那个暴躁的乐队。
先替你把情绪吼出来，
再让那个温柔的钢琴。
替你把心事说一遍，
等到最后一个人落下的时候，
你可能发现，
那些纠结，
已经被舒曼替你消化了一半。
下面的传响时间，
我们听的还是克里斯蒂安琴莫尔曼的演奏，
OK，我们说完舒曼，
接下来来听一个内心更泥巴的人，
柏拉姆斯。
刚才我们听到的是，
柏拉姆斯必大调
第一钢琴三重奏，
作品号第八的第一乐章，
这也是我最喜欢的一首。
沈内越作品。
他柏拉姆斯肯定绕不开。
泥巴这个词，
他情感上泥巴，
爱上了恩师舒曼的妻子，
克拉拉舒曼，
但这份情感，
他从头到尾都没有说破，
选择把爱意藏在心里。
性格上也泥巴，
他极其自我怀疑，
写一首曲子要反复改十几遍。
创作上也很泥巴，
他是浪漫主义时期最传统的作曲家，
明明身处浪漫主义浪超中，
却撇掉回头去研究巴赫，
摩拉特，贝多芬这些古典的结构。
那么这三重泥巴，
叠带一期就导致他写出来的旋律，
也有一种独特的泥巴感，
但这里的泥巴是保义词，
大家可以理解为他太担心情感过于外露，
所以总是在情感上盖着一层薄薄的理智。
他怕说的太多，
所以先会往前探一步，
然后又往后推半步，
那种克制的美感让他的旋律不只是好听，
更值得反复拒绝。
而且他的那种克制。
并没有切断音乐的流动感，
反让旋律更具连续性。
每个音符都像是经过反复推敲的，
不多不少。
刚好够你感受到他内心的暗涌。
那么把这首钢琴三重奏放进停止内耗歌单，
因为我觉得他其实是一首包容性很大的曲子，
你带着任何一种情绪去听他，
他都能接住你。
这首作品是柏拉姆斯二岁的时候写的，
是他出版的第一首使能乐作品，
但有意思的是柏拉姆斯在三十多年之后，
又把他拿出来重新写了一下。
我们今天听到版本，
其实是晚年柏拉姆斯，
对青年柏拉姆斯的一次修订。
所以在周曲子里面，
你能同时听到两种声音，
一种是二十岁的热情和冲动，
一种是五十多岁的克制和声思。
那我们来分场景听一看。
场景一，你此刻内耗到几点，
被某些人折磨到不行，
心里堵的黄，但又没法发作，
那我建议你直接从展开部的后半段开始听。
这里所有的乐器，钢琴小提琴大提琴，
全部都进入了某种失控的边缘，
音量大，节奏紧，
情绪相位逼到了墙角之后，
终于炸开，
但它就不是那种宣泄时的爆炸，
它拧绊，很挣扎，
所以大家可以跟着它们一起把那股劲耗完。
等这段时间过去，
你会发现自己也平静了一些。
场景二，你突然有个好消息，
但因为某些原因，
不能马上跟别人分享，
只能一个人憋着，
所以有点小雀跃，
带有点小落寞，
那你可以从头开始听。
第一人的主题有一种很奇特的质感，
它不是那种纯粹的快乐，
也不是纯粹的忧伤，
而是在两者之间反复很调，
那种想说又不能说的情绪，
被伯拉姆斯写得极其精准。
场景三，
你只是想转移注意力，
不想被任何人，
任何情绪牵着鼻子走，
那我建议你直接从九分钟之后开始听。
三天乐器，钢琴，
小提琴，大提琴，
每个人都在自说自话，
各走各的线条，
同时发声，互不打扰。
你可以在这种各自独立的声音里面。
给自己留住一点空间，
不用跟任何人解释，
不用照顾任何人的情绪，
就只是听着，
然后脑子放空。
最后一种内耗是场景，
是自闭式内耗，
这种内耗跟事无关，
也跟具体某个人的关系也不大，
它的根源在于环境，
可能是你身处在某个让你不舒服的空间，
或者只是周遭太吵了，
你只想安静地待着。
那么这个时候，
我一般会放就PR左拉的自由Tango的。
管弦乐改编版。
刚才我们听到的是，
PR左拉最著名的作品之一，
也是新Tango音乐的标志性曲目。
但我们今天听的这个是，
弦乐队的改编版本，
够造，够热闹，
也足够好听。
你把它音量开到最大，
不管是你在哪儿，
在地铁里，
在办公室里，
或者在户外，
都听不到别人说什么了。
那为什么要听这个弦乐队的版本呢？
而不是原版的五重奏，
因为我觉得弦乐队的版本的音色层次。
更加的吩咐，
尤其是弦乐群启奏的那种音量和厚度，
比单间乐器更有包裹感。
它像一床声音的被子，
把你整个人都裹进去，
隔绝外界，
切分音，
重音一味，
互宽互慢的绿动，
这些绿动有一种，
非常强的感染力，
你听着听着呢，
身体就会不自觉地跟着晃，
注意力也被带走。
听完皮尔奏了，
我们再来一首
同样造热型的曲子，
适合屏蔽外界声音。
刚才放到这段呢，
是柴可夫斯基的 F 小调，
第四将曲的第一乐章，
作品号是 36，
是指挥卡拉雅，
领贤维尔奈爱尔乐团的演奏。
那么这首曲子写于。
1877-78年之间，
是老柴提现给她的。
自助人梅克夫人的作品。
她在给梅克夫人的信中写道，
这首将曲写的是命运，
那个像达默克利斯剑一样。
悬在我们头上的东西，
无法战胜，只能忍受。
所以整部将曲就是从这种压迫感出发，
最终走向了对生活的一线希望。
第一人的开头就是著名的。
命运号角，
元号，小号骑奏，
音量很猛，气质很沉，
像一季重拳砸下来，
然后弦一组开始翻滚，
汹涌，情绪一层一层的对。
整个乐章就像一场情绪的暴风雨，
它会直接把你拉到风暴里，
让你在那种巨大的生长里面。
把自己压抑的情绪和烦躁。
一起震出去。
OK，前面的两首作品，
皮尔奏、达克夫斯基，
都是让你在躁热里面释放的，
但最后这首，
我想换一个角度来结束，
自毕是内耗这个话题。
我非常会觉得，
内耗产生有的时候，
是因为我们给这个世界太多好脸色了，
太把某些人当回事了，
道德感太强了，
太喜欢反思和折磨自己了。
遇到什么事情？
第一反应就是，
诶，是不是我哪里做得不好？
对，哪里做得不好？
但我想说，
如果你想快速的调解自己的心态，
能怪别人的事情，
千万别怪自己。
当你发现自己道德感过强的时候，
对自己要求过高的时候，
我建议大家去听一听瓦格纳。
刚才这段来自瓦格纳的歌剧，
《龙格林》的第三幕的前奏曲。
19世纪的德国作曲家瓦格纳，
他从龙格林之后的。
《推斯坦與索尔德》开始，
就特地改变了歌剧的写法。
他的音乐没有那种很强烈的断落感，
而是一条从头到尾不断流动的，
无穷无尽的旋律线，
他自己把这个叫做无中旋律。
配戚宏大，合声大胆，
对后使的马勒，
李朝社劳斯，
乃至电影配乐都产生了深远的影响。
他的音乐里没有任何讨好的姿态，
不会照顾大家的舒适区域，
他的目的就是要用庞大的音响把你推平。
这首前套曲写的非常的灿烂，
辉煌,
同款齐鸣，
弦越狂奔，
打击越鸿鸣，
整个乐队都是全速冲刺。
瓦格纳音乐的有种特质，
就是你听着它，
你不会想到是不是自己做错了什么，
只会觉得这个世界很大，
我很渺小，
那点破事算啥。
OK,
以上就是本期播客的所有内容，
我分了三个场景，
分享了八首作品，
而且每一首作品都是我清测有效的，
情绪挤下车。
当然对抗内耗这件事情，
我们不可能仅靠听几首作品，
就彻底解决它，
但它或许也未必需要被彻底的解决，
因为内耗它是一方面，
但是有内耗情节的另外一面，
也许这个人非常的敏锐，
共情力强，
直觉精准，
情感的，
细腻分配，
那么这些我觉得都是好的一面，
所以我觉得我们需要的呢，
只是找到一个方法，
在它来的时候，
让自己能平稳地度过，
那个阶段。
那么也希望大家喜欢这期播客的分享，
我们下期再见，
拜拜!